bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo meraviglioso fido perché oggi
giochiamo ad immortals phoenix reisen
che è un gioco è un gioco
la ragazza fatti scherzi sono caduto per
il fatto che lo sto provando in
anteprima e me lo stanno facendo provare
dall'altra parte del mondo in questo
momento mentre sto parlando c'è un
referente di ubisoft che mi sta
scontando mentre sto parlando ed è
inglese quindi non sta capendo una sega
di valori per dicendo
meno male allo ragazzi stiamo per
immergerci in un'avventura pazzesca sto
video qua sarà spettacolare perché un
gioco in mega anteprima dove ragazzi
allora stiamo uscendo dalla zona
tutorial perche velo schifata un
attimino ho capito non ho capito niente
ho capito un attimino come funziona ci
sono un sacco di comandi ma dovrei aver
mascherato un po la faccenda allora
parte sti leoni della madonna che
secondo me tra un po si prendono anche
abbastanza male quindi non sono nella
questo non devo riattivare le ventole
della fornace
questo è quello che mi chiede porca
vacca mi sono quasi bruciato giudizio
voglio vedere se scappare con 200
spettatori
facciamo vedere alla fia
guardando il gameplay che sono forte io
c'ho fi videogiochi bene basta è
abbastanza un casino perché mi si deve
di caricare la l'energia tra virgolette
non energia va bene l'hack è male ok che
quella assolutamente azzurra ciò anche
la pozione che nella di carica
abbastanza velocemente
però se non sono skillato e non me lo
ricordo non è colpa mia ma stellati in
faccia a posto meraviglioso ragazzi
l'obiettivo è andare là sopra cosa
impossibile per la sicuro di fare un
giro abnorme ma il mio tentativo è
lecito e ci provo letto eccolo perfetto
ok o dix bravo questo intendevo anche
prima sarebbe stato utile fare così ma
non fa niente ci riprovo ci arrivo ci ho
messo un sacco per arrivare qua sopra
sono molto soddisfatto di me stesso ho
trovato la forza degli dei
meraviglioso allora ragazzi vedo colosso
gigante davanti a me quindi sarà a
cazzotti sicuro boss fight
sono contento di questo il pelato della
boss fight no secondo me questo lo
faccio fuori col martello poi io ci
provo poi non lo so senza paura solo
verdura
è meraviglioso lega ci vediamo in
un'altra vita è stato bello comunque
divertente ragazze lo farò ce l'ho fatta
una sega realtà cioè spero di farcela
adesso
ma non è che forse spaventato anch'io
penso di fare bene è stato più difficile
del previsto soprattutto se non sai
comandi va bene o quell'enigma da fare
sicuro no l'ho fatto di dover risolvere
l'enigma o ristorato ceo risorse che
sono un tecnico dell'evento ridotta
questo è tecnico dell'evento del
simulator
oddio che se questo che c'hai vedo
harvey qua gardel cessano devo
assolutamente andare nella gara del cev
fermi fermi tutti ragazzi devo andare
nella cat
credo che sia una uno scrigno protetto
in poche parole gardel certo non so che
cosa c'è dentro ma ci proviamo vedo
cerca far fuori il suo quad all'altro
dato non mi può far niente so quadri di
ascensore lo zio quando vai io mando rai
che fai schifo ma dove ma cosa colpisci
ma cosa colpi
como donna che adesso scendo guardati
world of usati sono mancati ma l'ho
preso
però non era morto è beccato è comunque
è comunque lo zio fa vi sento gente
funghi
no ragazzi non sono una ditta dei funghi
come tempo sembrava perché questa roba
qui veramente utile tv in cui si
recupera l'energia blu che devono le
vallette di tutte le altre visto che
effettivamente ti permette di fare gli
attacchi molto più feste io riesco a
sbloccare la porta l'ha detto che la
porta
credo che io debba andare di sopra dove
dire una cacata però qua sopra c'è un
coso rosso di quelli che puoi staccare
per eccolo qua perfetto praticamente ci
sono due maledizione due ore avrà per in
staffetta ragazzi tra queste c'è
qualcosa ma penso sia per aprire il
portello
ok funghi prima di tutto funghi funghi
funghi funghi funghi e va laici sono un
tecnico delle ventole che va a funghi
semplicemente ragazzo mi piace stavolta
come come detto no brand e chest questa
ragazzi con questa tattica è veramente
[ __ ] e per aprire le case io ve la
consiglio rimane che fuori chiusi da
casa fate papa papa sulla porta
meraviglioso cosa che mi ha dato
non ho capito niente dopo un elmo sono
un brutto come la morte volevo provare a
prendere un cavallo ragazzi volevo
prendere un cavallo perché secondo me si
può fare solo che si agitano io sono
fermi sono già citati non ho fatto
niente quale sicuro tranquillo mi
avvicino individuo proprio isimm askoll
dei cavalli
frate frate citate per quale motivo le
sorprendenti suicidare tu non sto
facendo niente
sono fermo fermo fermo sono fermo sono
perno sono immobile euro sta iniziando
ad essere scappi allo stesso fatti
cavalcare riposo di un cavallo
ecco niente io gli voglio bene cavalli
adesso sto scherzando
però è che in questo gioco sono
difficilmente cavalcabili bellissimo
adesso ciò quiksilver salve signor
quiksilver d'argento veloce quasi della
roba occhio giovanni occhio di toglierti
la link qua c'è il punto dove devo
lavorare io non ci siamo ancora
presentati io faccio il quello che mette
a posto le cose come si chiamano le
l'evento le faccio questo lavoro in
tutti sti buchi devo far passare una
freccia e poi se finisco di down prender
scommettete la vedo troppo vino che cosa
ci provo
123 addio addio è difficilissimo ragazzi
veramente difficilissimo ci riprovo ok
per ora tutto a posto
per ora tutto appare ora tutto a posto
tutto meravigliosamente bene quanto dura
sta roba
ok grande e meraviglioso ed ha sbloccato
la mi ha dato delle monete v3 di charme
di ciò che è successo coi sandali si
maledice a due altri due sono uno stato
bravissimo
in tutto questo la società gigante che
vorrei prendere con le frecce ma non c'è
bisogno lo sono già cosa state facendo
arrivo a quello fatto male secondo me
ragazzi quei volevi cosa succede si
chiama sparate orca vacca ragazzi a
leone dove leone amico mio
leone amico mio cosa è andato che stanno
questi che mi stanno a spara eccoti qua
ti dà una mano vai fratello e il nostro
momento nel nostro momento si può
brillare
ho sbagliato scusami ma volevo non
volevo taglia sempre tasto si scusa li
ho fatti allontanare tutti adesso paduli
secondo me se ne sono accorti ma forse
anche al piano giorno
entrare qui dentro sono infatti entrare
c'è troppa gente la uccide ragazza o il
demonio c'è pure medusa quest'anno devi
guardare negli occhi soldi com'è
possibile che noi stiamo ora negli occhi
no ragazzi scusatemi non volevo fare
comunella laviani butto giù dai big a
chi mi suicido è stato non posso
suicidarmi perché cesta parte della the
move aveva niente
vedete voi quello che vedo io perfetto i
ragazzi questa che morda al phoenix
rising quello che un tempo venne
chiamato cose monster spero vi sia
piaciuto e volevo ringraziare la ubisoft
problemi sono sponsor avrebbero fatto
provare in anteprima e per aver
sponsorizzato anche biogas e viva
ragazzi spero che il mio che vi sia
piaciuto schede a calare e fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate del gioco e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video e
l'aria
[Musica]